l comme vous avez eu des hauts et des
bas on va vous faire une interview à
peine d'armes
on ne bouge pas pendant le dîner galles
je ne crois pas ah je le crois pas après
deux semaines de 40 l arrivée le 11
revenir
la révolution est en marche et je réagis
visas non mais on se réveille des
associations des mouvements des partis
qui peut fuir à varennes mais on va te
couper la tête
quoi qu'il arrive une fille qui me suit
un seul de huit mois et j'interdis à mon
bébé de bouger pendant le jingle est
effective dans le dcu diana qui
s'appelle géant les deux façons mais
tellement éclaté quand risque pas de
bouger par le jingle rassure toi j'aime
bien et puis il ya étonnant la terre a
tremblé à casablanca samedi dernier je
savais pas sauf pendant le jingle me dit
ah mais c'est bon dave est ce que vous
êtes prêts pour l'interviewer n'daw
qu'est ce que vous préférez en bout la
loyauté est ce que vous détestez où la
trahison
qu'est ce que vous préférez dans la
chanson mélodies puisque vous détestez
dans la chanson alors à votre chanson
préférée c'est quoi un gros c verra on
se rencontrera il ya 3000 dit dans cette
très très riches la chanson vous
détestez le plus au genre danse des
canards que été le plus grand moment de
votre vie professionnellement le plus
grand moment c'est en fait quand j'ai
fait la première fois l'olimpia 77-76 un
moment dans mon tour de chant
l'applaudissement du quatrième chanson
que la décision durer plus longtemps que
normalement et sentais que j'avais gagné
et c'est vrai que c'est un moment
vraiment super quoi le pire mais monde
quand on a 50 ils ont puisque vous êtes
fait tout cela colle piscine et donc
s'ils sont aussi moment lié ni à la mort
liée au sida sans ça c'est aussi le
temps pour 56 ans avait plutôt bien
conservé quand même non quel est ton
secret les spern ce qui vous plaît le
plus dans la vie
aujourd'hui sans aucun doute je pense
que je dirais le soleil sur la peau est
ce qui vous plaît le moins ce qu'ils
peuvent voir de moi c'est
l'incompréhension que j'ai pour cet
événement fichiers mais pour
l'intolérance roues pour pas qu'ils
n'ont pas tous envie de rester au soleil
en lisant des bons bouquins en buvant
bon verre de vin qui trouve le temps de
se taper dessus pour des raisons de
pouvoir se comprend pas bien vu que
c'est un grand enfant d'un petit
branleur à camoufler
il vous fait le plus rire dans la vie
une valeur d ordre je veux ma vie n'est
pas que les cheveux qui vont pas ce qui
vous fait le moins rire la connerie est
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
le battre il va évidemment oui ya 25 ans
qu'il venait dé l'hôtel je disais il ya
est la plus moche histoire vraiment je
n'ai pas à m'en parler moi si ça d'amour
se distend moi je veux pas d'histoires
d'amour tout balladur on peut dire oui
qu'est-ce que vous avez de plus sexy en
vous oui l'argent je sais pas ce que
jésus marche j'avais oublié le nom mais
c'est vrai que ça me disons que par les
révisions et insertion d'un beau bleu
j'viens autrement une fois d'une le
journaliste qui est arrivé six mois au
moment où je marchais vraiment pas
encore du nouveau et qui m'a dit qu'est
ce que ça vous fait d'être un gars
d'être un has been through social
assis sur mon fauteuil de dans
l'appartement où se trouve payer le
loyer j'ai pendant toute l'interview de
le regarder droit dans les yeux en
vraiment en m'imaginant d'y faire passer
le message que tu me plais j'invite tous
les trous et massey energy et elle m'a
écrit un article formidable ça marche et
ça avec des joueur le plus sexy ce sont
les yeux le moins sexy
le corps d'un homme de 56 ans d'une
catastrophe d'hier
c'est un remède contre l'eire